après avoir été boxeur puis militaire
squeeze se met aujourd'hui à une
activité plus viril que ces deux
dernières
c'est là que sont ses dires une
punchline
messieurs dames une table de ping pong
était trop cher pour nous du coup on
achetait un htc walsky plus cher
aujourd'hui on est sur un jeu de ping
pong envers ces parties multi eisa ne
savait ok alors écoutez on est sûr
eleven au ping pong je me suis un peu du
nom un jeu auquel on peut jouer en multi
player contre d'autres joueurs dans le
monde le problème c'est qu'on a essayé
de thaler et qu'il y avait personne qui
veut jouer au curling
heureusement l'option jouer seul comme
un puceau et présente clément est ce
qu'on est un amateur
un semi pro un professionnel oui ce
qu'on est un joueur de légende jo tu
t'enflammes un peu gamin professionnel
ce sera un excellent début allez on y va
attention service à temps ses débuts
c'est normal 1-0 pour lui clément onians
tombe
wen zhao ont ils fait il prévient même
pas aux pays-bas où toi je vais district
et vidéo attendra t main après en fait
le cas ce qui n'est pas très stable à
son de ckoi je vais dire un truc et
musique étaient graves ne se dégage au
quai 3 pour lui là on se saisit de koné
la génoise en même temps je suis un banc
de touche pas un truc d'asia qu'est ce
que put un mec je me fais des moyens la
gueule c'est terrible pourtant je suis
impressionné charger de légende jouer
contre les plus grands je veux qu'on
david lafarge mon pote rires ouais ses
fossettes un bon à savoir on est bien
comme on dit rien n'est jamais perdu mes
nerfs c'est bon c'est fini
bonsoir faire soit fermeture au match
échauffement terminée c'est parti les
issers je m'en bats les couilles au plat
non là par contre mecs trop mal fait
mais que faire des grosses match était
prêt à voir des gros ce match [ __ ]
j'ai pas touché la balle
8-0 smara disparaissent pas interdit
regardes tu as vu ou pas je nique et un
pigeon hockey joueur professionnel tu
vas voir
hop là c'est super milan ce qui se passe
j'ai acheté la tenue est tout et je veux
aller 1 partout c'est le début de la
victoire pour le cas au charbon j'avoue
j'ai changé de figure et j'ai mis en
amateur aulaqi est fort violent
j'ai mis en amateur mais ça me permet
voiliers de comprendre comment ça marche
le big bang a été bien que plus tard
avec le ping pong ans
en réalité tout court finalement je
pense qu'il faut rester stable en fait
rire je vais rester stables rien rien
rien rien rien stabilité toi c'est
l'heure du conte nous ces deux piliers
jaune dessus
franchement je suis over ridicule mais
mec depuis je fais ça je gagne autant
dire que je vais pas lâcher cette
position allez ça va je trouve ridicule
en plus j'ai attrapé un peu froid aux
boules parce que l'air passe et on s'en
fout 8,6 pour l'obtenir montrent que les
marges peuvent atteindre tant qu'amateur
ne pas faire cours de maths ok ok
ok ok bloqués t'as vu ta vu la technique
du jeu changeait de m c'est fou hein o o
les chiens errants
la chute a laissé un 11-3 faut que je
gagne je suis là au 9/9 commencé quand
même sacré je vais battre un amateur il
fait quoi
non mais clémence un vieux gars mais
vraiment atteint les plages pas qu'il
m'envoie un truc dans les moules mais
pas non mais c'est pas drôle c'est que
cet homme joue au ping pong c'est qui
dans la vie ne peut rien faire d'autre
un virage 15 pas la raquette bâtard
c'est le club qui tu es prête j'ai voulu
se moquer balle de match clément tu
crois moi ouais ouais quoi c'était pas
mon choix mais c'est un sketch mec info
deux points d'écart mais finalement
pourquoi tu me lis pas séparés c'est pas
toi et pilier ils sont en plastique
concentré j'ai concentré chez entre
adrien domec dans un jeu de ping-pong
virtuel m'a dit c'est ça tough howe s
est passé à les haïr hd ou flex est
partie la faute gnc la merci allez on
est chaud on part sur un match en
semi-pro la grenouille oui les chômeurs
tabarand le poids des ans beaucoup trop
longtemps clément ah non en fait
et le problème c'est les coups droits je
trouve ça super dur de doser le sait
l'effet que tu mets dans la balle non je
veux renvoyé du rêve au genre je veux
mettre ce match mais je veux m je te dis
je mettrai à ce match avant la fin
[ __ ] parle je remonte 6 1 pour lui
mais je renom clément oui oui 6 2 celle
de millions dans monte d'un mec pour de
vrai les ce match est impossible 9 2-9 2
c'est quoi c'est l'autre scène ça nous
fait plaisir
voilà super 10 2 c'est quoi c'est la
défaite allez on peut remonter balle de
match pour lui on peut mettre du point
10-3 c'est martigues le mans s'est passé
comment tu vois ses jambes c'est quoi
ces des piliers actuellement il faut que
ce soit quoi des grenouilles riz match
mec je veux gravir les échelons comme un
chanteur après the voice 1-0 pour lui ok
si drôle c'est que pluie mais une
branlée puis devient nul ça c'est bien
fait c'est que les développeurs et si on
dit bon les mecs sont venus on va
connaître un peu pitié d'eux oh ça joue
bien là oh là là t'as vu j'ai fait un
début de match sur le vrai ce match
arrive aulas moi je suis là tu m'a
ralenti
justement par des études merde mec je me
dis de la vraie vie je vois tellement
est une grosse merde à ce moment précis
entre adverse à dans le vide vestiaires
c'est hyper-important faut que je gagne
quand soudain un match entre un dominé 4
3 tu vois le sport c'est aussi beaucoup
de moral si le moral je suis pas le
physique suit pas c'est pas ça je
voulais dire six mois elle va pas le
physique ne suit pas ok 10,3 clément
balle de match aller service hop là
c'est mort on atteint quatre matches ces
pourvois de son ce match aller à la plus
mon mec il est temps de passer à quelque
chose de plus un professionnel ou
légendaires je pense qu'on peut dire
pour les professionnels ça fait cinq
minutes qu'on joue alain les pros ouah
ouah où il a coupé décalé mon gars dans
mes mecs il veut m'aider balcer des
fusées des fusées tu vois ce pays six
sociétés bas ils seront toujours il se
met k les balles de match pour lui c'est
parti on remonte on l'a laissé croatie
et y danse j'ai envie de l'exploser il
est virtuel mais j'ai envie de les
matches c'est parti
je vais bien poids je vais pas passer ma
victoire j'ai mis un point en équilibre
les iem
ça fait que gagner alors on est donc
maintenant en catégorie presque
légendaire ça va être incroyable au bien
joué il fait des balles longues mec non
mais ce n'est pas possible tu vois ces
petits mouvements vie là c'est quand
même explosé raconté combien j'ai fait
des mouvements vifs comme ça c'est donc
deux fois il m'a exposé autant dire qu'à
et 11 0 c'est parti
oh le maquis mais y met une carotte il
me met une carotte dans le jeu et le
smash ce match non mais qu à masquer ma
raquette passe après la mecque podium
clément 18 fois dans la gaieté passat à
la balle aurait il s'agit ou pas à m'en
faut pas déconner m romeyer moi mais je
viens de remettre les caisses nilmar
mais une carotte qu'est ce tu vas faire
face à metz match j'ai gagné voilà
c'était mon arbitrage et les 6 700 de
vidéos ne te plaît pas je comprends pas
à quoi il n'ya pas cette vidéo sur le
jeu de ping pong et ses hyper et merci
mme diouf est en fait dès que le jeu
atteint une certaine vitesse
j'aime son que avec la latence des
capteurs extérieurs galère un petit peu
à ses excuses de rajoute us et crédible
ouais c'est suffisant à des moyens mais
non merci dorian et portez vous bien
si vous voulez faire du ping pong
franchement 20 balles par mois au club
près de chez toi c'est mieux tu as vu